Wow, Oscar… you sure have a selective memory.
Per tradition, Sunday night's Academy Awards
telecast featured an "In Memoriam" segment
that honored notable personalities we've lost
over the last year and, also per tradition,
a number of beloved entertainment giants were
inexplicably omitted.
The Twitterverse quickly took notice, and,
as you might imagine, folks had some pretty
harsh words for the Academy.
Among this year's many snubs, veteran character
actor Dick Miller is one of the most notable
celebrities who didn't make the cut.
"I expect to see you in the funnies any day
now… with Smiling Jack and Little Abner."
He's perhaps best known for his role in the
1984 Joe Dante classic Gremlins.
Miller's prolific career spanned six decades,
with his filmography stretching from the '50s
until just last year.
The pop culture website A.V.
Club also pointed out the snub, noting that
Miller's
"... ubiquity as a character actor sadly didn't
translate to the Oscars."
The name Gary Kurtz probably rings a bell.
Although his body of work wasn't exactly a
mile long, his legacy lies in a little film
he took a chance on back in the 1970s.
"Oh, you said it, Chewy."
In case you somehow haven't guessed, that
film is Star Wars, which Kurtz co-produced
along with The Empire Strikes Back — not
to mention Jim Henson's 1982 fantasy classic
The Dark Crystal.
"Oh no, right in the mud."
If that's not an impressive resume, we really
don't know what is.
How could the Academy fail to mention Carol
Channing, who passed away on January 15, 2019?
In 1968, the legendary entertainer was nominated
for a Best Supporting Actress Oscar for her
performance in Thoroughly Modern Millie.
"Raspberries!"
She's even presented at the Oscars before.
"And what a thrill it is to fondle an Oscar
even in transit."
Still, Channing got no love from the Academy
at this year's ceremony.
That obviously didn't sit well with one Twitter
user, who simply stated that Channing was
an Oscar nominee over and over until he ran
out of characters.
Can you blame him?
The Academy also failed to mention Verne Troyer,
who shot to worldwide fame as Mini-Me in the
Austin Powers films.
Where was Al Matthews, who appeared in James
Cameron's 1986 masterpiece Aliens, one of
the greatest science fiction films of all
time?
What about veteran character actor R. Lee
Ermey, who's scene-stealing performance in
Full Metal Jacket made him one of the most
memorable film characters ever?
"Why, you little maggot, you make me want
to vomit!"
And then there's John Mahoney, best known
for his role as Martin Crane in the long-running
TV series Frasier.
That's a lot of amazing talent... but we saved
the biggest omission for last.
"You better think about what you saying.
You better think about the consequences of
your actions."
That's right.
Aretha Franklin, the Queen of Soul, wasn't
included in the memorial... despite being
one of the greatest vocalists the world has
ever seen… or heard rather.
She had a number of film and television credits
on her resume, particularly a standout appearance
in the 1980 classic The Blues Brothers.
"Now you're not going back on the road no'
mo'... and you ain't playing no two-bit sleazy
dive."
Each year, the "In Memoriam" segment serves
as a way for good ol' Oscar to shoot himself
in the foot.
In that regard, the 2019 edition did not disappoint.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.